let's have a look at this now first on
is we're gonna answer for two already a
radius of two point eight centimeters
what do you think yeah looking good and
you can actually see ku she's very
helpfully giving us some working have a
look into the first line I think it's
pretty much bang on it they got the
right better answer than this well what
does this line me can you look carefully
at the top line was it me yeah perfect
this is literally the volume formula but
it's been substituted correctly yet
right we we don't know what the rate is
is so she's naked said that's the height
as per the diagram and that's the volume
as said in the question and the working
just worked out which is why I'm giving
a big thumbs up to that now this will
appear I've seen a few different answers
around the room so before we get to what
this is I want to show all of you how to
do pro numerals on your calculator
because I said remember I said in
equations they're great because you
never need to doubt you could always
just test pop your number into the top
line and then just see what happens if
it's right you should get the same thing
on both science but with something like
this it's a little less straight boy so
let me show you how and for this thing I
just want your pants out of your hands
please
watch with me very carefully and go one
step at a time I apologize I know not
everyone has the same calculator as me
I'm fairly sure though most of you do
and first who were different we can work
out what the functions are so here's
what I'm going to do on your calculator
on and on there's quite a few steps to
this so I'm short to you first and then
I'll write it down
but it's important you follow me because
you obviously you miss one step there
like what's going on I don't have to do
names so we paying very close attention
once you go through some calculations
suppose you get a number as an answer so
I'm going to put it in and can we all
put it in four Elevens okay so once
you're in too deep or 11 so maybe you
tidied 4/11
I want you to know it's here in the
in the bottom right hand corner oh by
the way Michelle should have asked
before can you see this on there or is
it too bright because I never it's all
right 3 2 okay now this is really
important while the 411 is there in the
display not just here it's got to be
there what's the buttons on I'm about to
press see this button here and the sort
of in the middle the bottom of the gray
ones it says our CL that stands for
recoil or come back to them a second
just above it it says sto which stands
for store so I can use this button to
store it's a bit hard to see on here but
you should have a bunch of red letters
above here I've got ABCDE F X Y and M
you might just have up you might have
less letters map it that should be
pretty close so watch how I'm gonna do
this button for button I'm gonna go
shift then I'm going to press recall you
all know you did it right
if up here in the top left hand corner
it says store then you just have to pick
a letter I'm gonna pick a because I'll
actually know why not pick X so X is
there right so I'm not gonna press any
other buttons just this bracket which I
X above it okay if you've done it right
it'll say that do you notice that have
you got it okay fantastic
now what that means is now you can use
the letter X the printing room X and
every time you write in X it'll say
411's so watch what do we go here on the
left hand side I've got 1 minus 2 X on 3
so here's my fraction I'm gonna write 1
minus 2 and to get to the X did you
notice next to the shift button there's
an alpha button stands for alphabet so
if you press alpha and then press the
bracket again it'll give you an X and
the calculator has designated that as 4
Elevens so now I'll complete the
fraction it gives me that okay so I'm
just testing you right so that's what
the left-hand side is I keep that in my
mind 1 over 11 and then I just test out
the right-hand side it exactly the same
way this is actually a very easy example
so I could do it in my head
if you want to just say X divided by
four and sure enough thumbs up whatever
level okay
now this becomes very very handy later
on if you end up having like some
cardboard mess on one side like man I
don't want to do that in my head and
manipulate it you can quickly work out
whether you've got the right answer or
not how am I supposed to be negative
is it eleven over four or forever eleven
I can never remember you can test it you
don't have any doubt does that make
sense so now pick up your pens and let's
just write this because I promise you
the next time you need this will
probably far enough in the future that
you do remember how we did this okay so
here's what you do step one get an
answer like hit equals to whatever
calculation you're doing like we did
4/11 once you hit equals then you've got
a number here it has to be there
otherwise this whole process doesn't
matter okay once your answer is equals
that the second thing to do is you go
shift and then do you remember which
button it was ah now I said I would come
back to that if you've got a whole bunch
of met it's like you've got ABCDE
whatever you can check what a number is
by saying not don't press shift just say
recall hex so watch this I'm going to
clear everything and just say recall X
and it faithfully returns me whatever
value I put in there okay so you might
be working with lots of different
numbers I remember what I used so recall
we'll get it for you to store it shift
recall and then pick a letter big no-no
if you actually do this in your working
and you do it substantially I recommend
that when you've got your answer here
you actually say something like over
here four over or eleven into X just be
yourself to remember some of the
questions we're going to look at later
yeah really quite long and you just
won't remember what you put where so
just write to me Joe once you've done
that to retrieve that pretty
the per any rule you press the gym every
which one was in the top alpha you press
that and then again you just pick a
letter whichever one you want or
whichever ones you're currently using
and that will stay what it is until you
embrace it so even if I turn the
calculator off which I will do right now
if you turn off you turn it back on
again you say recall X it's still there
in fact if you want to get rid of it you
have to purposefully clear it which is
what this clear button is above nine I
can show you how to do that you want but
there's no reason why not if I get
something else like say oh I don't know
the square root of sorry the square root
of seven point nine five five sorry five
seven and whatever it is suppose that
number is important to me maybe I want
that to be X now if I go shift recall X
it just wipes out whatever was there
before so my four over eleven s is gone
now that's what X isn't it or it won't
remember what it was okay so this is
super super handy you'll keep on using
it all the way through year 11 and 12 so
it's worth having the idea now